So having given you the high level description
of what ANTS toolkit does, let's dig a little
deeper and look at the structure of the
ANTS capsule as well as the APIs provided by
ANTS in order to do capsule processing. First
of all, the header as I told you consists
of three parts. The original IP header, which
is important for routing the package towards the destination
if a node is a normal node, not an active node.
And this is of course the payload that was generated by
the application. And in the middle is this ANTS header, and
there are two fields in this ANTS header that are particularly
important. One is a type field, the other is a prev
field. The type field is a way by which you can
identify the code that has to be executed to process this
capsule. And this type field is really an MD5 hash of the
code that needs to be executed on this capsule,
and we'll come back to that in a minute. And
the second field that I said is important is
the prev field. And this prev field is the identity
of the upstream node that successfully processed the capsule
of this type. And this information is going to be
useful for us in terms of identifying the code that
needs to be executed in order to process this capsule.
We'll come back to how these two fields are
actually used in processing a capsule once this capsule arrives
at an active node. The short hint that I'll
give you is that the capsule itself, as you see,
does not contain the code that needs to be
executed to process this capsule, but it only contains a
type field. And this type field is a vehicle by
which we can identify the code that needs to be
executed to process this capsule. More on that
in a minute. First, let's talk about the
API that ANTS toolkit provides you. The most
important function that we want to accomplish using the
ANTS toolkit is forwarding packets through the network
intelligently. So routing the capsule is the most important
function that needs to be done. And that's
most of what this ANTS API is all about.
And that part is contained right here, saying that,
well, route this packet in this manner, and deliver
the packet to an application. And this is the
set of API calls that allows you to do
routing of the capsule through the network. This is
where what I said about virtualizing the network comes
in. Regardless of the actual topology, physical topology, I
can take routing decisions commensurate with the network flow requirements
contained in the capsule that arrives at a node.
So the second part of the API is API
for manipulating what is called a soft-store. Now, soft-store
is storage that's available in every routing node for
personalizing the network flow with respect to a particular
type of capsule. And I mentioned earlier that the
type is only a pointer to the code, not
the code itself. And the soft-store is a place where
we can store the code that corresponds to
a particular capsule type. So the primitives that
are available for manipulating the soft-store are things
like put object and get object. The soft-store
is basically key value store and in this
key value store, you can store whatever is
important for personalizing the network flow for capsules
of this type. An obvious candidate for storing
in the soft-store is the code that is associated with
this type. So you can store the code that is
associated with this type, so that future capsules of the
same type, when it arrives at a particular node, they can
retrieve the code from the soft-store and execute the code
that needs to be executed for processing capsules of this type.
Other interesting things that you might put into this soft-store
are things like computed hints about the state of the network,
which can be used for future capsule processing for capsules of
the same type. And the third category of API that's available
is querying the node for interesting tidbits about the state of
the network or details about that node itself, for instance, what
is the identity of the node that I'm currently at, and
what the local time is at this node, at this node,
and so on and so forth. So these are the kinds
of things that are available. So the key thing that I want
you to get out of looking at this ANTS API is that it is a very, very minimal
setup API. So the number of API calls fits in this little table here. So that's
the idea. Remember that routers are in the
public Internet. And if you're talking about executing code
in the router that is part of the public
Internet, the router program that we're executing at a
router node has to have certain important characteristics. Number
one, it has to be easy to program. Number two,
it should be easy to debug, maintain, and understand. And
number three, it should be very quick, because we are
talking about routing packets, and so the router program should
not take a long time to do its router processing.
So the API, this very simple API, allows you to
generate very simple router programs that are easy to program
because the APIs are simple, easy to debug,
easy to maintain and understand. And the program itself
is pretty small, that it's going to take not a
humongous amount of time to do the packet processing.